oh hello ladies gentlemen these and gays
the trailer editors have been burning
the midnight oil and i will admit it
looks pretty great with all sound
effects going pewdiepie and the music's
like
i am just so excited to share with you
the trailer for harley quinn season 3
coming to hbo max
gotham city
demons are rising up criminals breed in
the shadows
my home needs
nightwing uh anyone want to switch seats
harley and ivy are back and once again
our house is at home my girlfriend came
up with the most badass plan ever hit it
ivy word of terraform gotham reclaiming
every inch from humans
great plan sorry if this clap sounds
sarcastic i sprained my hand playing
table tennis
big changes are gonna happen
i tried being a villain but that's the
old me
i want to be someone my family can be
proud of that's why i'm running for
mayor
sorry i thought you were ready for that
we locked eyes
goblin city is going great
how is an ivy plan even more of a
disaster than a harley plank
holy sanitized curse words this is wrong
innocent people are dying is it just me
or just army seem a little different
i believe she's going through what is
known as some [ __ ]
i thought you were doing this together
harley you've changed
did you just kill him to contradict him
don't read into it
and tell ben affleck i upper decked his
fancy sodastream
wow
i did it success
now i'm not going to repeat what that
plant said but he hates you
[Music]
what's with your voice what are you
talking about it's a bit overly serious
i think it's an appropriate amount of
serious seriously i'd rather you killed
me
you